- Yeah, I mean look,
I think it depends
on how you look at it.
I mean, do I think
new things happen?
Not that often.
I think everybody's
being fucked with because
the attention is being staggered
in so many different directions
and shifts very quickly.
If you were all of our parents,
our moms and dads, if they were
marketers a generation ago
they had it easy.
We had a consistent
platform of marketing
for a very long time.
The internet, that's the thing
being delivered in
the phone by the way,
that thing screwed it up.
It's tough now. Sorry.
Do you think I'm happy that
Twitter's losing it's attention?
I have 1.2 million
followers on it.
I was at the top of the heap.
I was winning.
I'm super pissed.
I'm sad, I'm not happy about it
but I'm not crying about it.
I'm learning and executing
in Instagram and Snapchat
and that's just the way it is
and it's gonna move fast
and what we have,
and again, because
Bonin's here and the context
of a lot of people in the room,
in a corporate environment,
again, the whole thing is
mis-structured.
You have brand managers.
These are business operators.
These are people that
think about profit margin,
actually the
formula of the cookies.
They have to think
about their relationships
with their retailers
and on top of all of that
they have to understand
what's going on in marketing
and they and some
random creative director
from Wieden and
Kennedy get to decide
what the creative is
that they're gonna spend
all their money on.
It's such a fucked up system.
It makes no common
sense in a 2016 world
and there's a reason so many
people struggle to sell shit
because they don't know how.
It's not that it's ripped apart.
It's like, one more time,
two humans in the world
decide what 30 second video
is gonna drive their business
and deliver it in a platform
where every one of us are
running away from
consuming it at all costs.